[Music]
in the wacky world of infomercials there
is one man that is the most famous face
in the industry it's OxiClean it gets
the tough tough stains out kaboom
this is the turbo scrub the rechargeable
cordless power scrubber then of course
there's the incredible sticky buddy its
slippy when it's wet and it's sticky
when it's dry hi Anthony Sullivan here
for the sticky buddy
I am a pitchman by trade look at that it
cuts right through this soft skin tomato
I'm so excited I'm getting out of breath
a pitchman just excels at being able to
sell certain products where is the oxy
clean shot this Superman's cape oxy
clean
gets the tough stains out of here my
teeth looks good
I started off selling when I was 22 at a
street market in England and one day I
turned on the television and I saw my
first infomercial and a light bulb went
off in my head I thought I need to get
in front of the TV camera and get off
the street some of the products that
we've sold over the years of the Swivel
Sweeper
the turbo scrub the sticky buddy
OxiClean orange glow this hurricane spin
mop clever cam on the list is endless it
has quad brush technology forwards
backwards or side to side and the worst
part is we didn't charge the battery I
think one of the most common questions I
ever get asked is does it really work as
good as it works which i think is one of
the reasons why people are attracted to
as seen on TV because you're like you
gotta see this product you see what it
does does everything clean your toilet
or clean your card or clean your washing
machine or clean your floors it'll clean
this
Matt I love it when I can do a Wow demo
that people sit at home and go oh my God
look at that Rudy works it's the power
of air it's been a struggle I haven't
had the wind behind me the whole way but
it's been an amazing journey and I
continue to really really enjoy what I
do
I'm never doing that again this is a
billion dollars we think and that
billion dollars belongs to r.j. Rapoport
and he's considered the king of cash
your fake cash okay king of fake cash my
name is rich r.j. Rappaport and I'm the
president of RJR props just a few years
ago actually it was nine years ago
oh sorry nine years ago RJR props was
born it's a full-service prop house but
its specialty is cash think cash and
there's only a few people who can
legally make it and RJ is one of them we
work with 50 cent
Kendrick Lamar Lil Wayne Fat Joe Young
Dolph and that's just to name a few
RJ's prop money has been used in over
175 feature films television shows and
music videos and he devoted three full
years to perfecting that crisp green
paper we call money prop money
and we went down a long path and working
with the Secret Service and learning all
the laws to make sure that everyone that
uses it it will be legal for them and
it'll look fantastic but for those who
don't follow the rules they could wind
up in big trouble there is a rash of
arrests people were just literally
jailed because they were using prop
money that looked too real and I said to
myself I'm not gonna touch this unless I
know I'm doing it legally alongside the
Secret Service RG created two different
styles of prop money one that is printed
on both sides and is perfect for that
classic bank robbery scene the other
kind is so close to the real deal it can
only be printed on one side otherwise it
could end up in circulation it's
designed for the classic money shot aka
this the close-up it's a tough business
we all work hard in it and prop money
especially it's not easy yeah sounds
like it
thanks RJ for keeping fake money real
[Music]
just 45 minutes north of the US border
is a city called Langley
it's a typical City there is a casino
tree-lined streets and of course a
ghanaian tribal chief this is Eric Manu
he works in Langley as a gardener for
this woman Susan Watson in Canada yard
work is a year-round occupation you'd be
surprised how busy we are during the
winter back to Eric Eric's story began
with a phone call last July yeah my
uncle died and I got a call to take over
that responsibility as a chief of my
community and I see a bubble number two
he said something like really are you
kidding me I said when I give it a try
so he went back to Ghana and became
chief but he decided to return to
Langley and this is when Susan got
involved and where our contemporary
story begins everything that happened
after Eric became chief I have seen so
much in Canada as my own experience and
I also want my people to have some kind
of opportunity in life with Susan Eric
is working on raising funds and
collecting donations to help set up
medical clinics for his tribe to improve
education overall he's trying to make
life better for his people back home we
started the Munna back foundation to
help the people in Ghana we've collected
more than two 20-foot containers full of
donated items my Jaime has been a very
successful Jenny although I'm a chief in
Ghana
I'm proud working as a gardener to
support and give my people the exposure
I'm proud of my community I'm proud of
my family and I'm proud to be an African
and I'm proud to be a Gunny
[Music]
there's really no difference between
here and home it's just everything's
compacted down to a 14 by 14 room once
you start staffing your look out you're
gonna be working ten days on four days
off late June until usually mid
September it's a pretty quiet existence
this is my 24th season there's a fire
lookout and really it's just you in the
wind and the time just melts away
my name is leif Hagen and we're at Toma
lookout but fire lookout is a structure
that sits on top of a mountain or ridge
top that has a good view of the
surrounding country and the staff are
then is tasked with living there for
extended periods to watch for fire it's
funny cuz I get a lot of questions about
the standard day you wake up with the
Sun I mean it's hard to sleep in a room
of glass much beyond sunrise first thing
I'll do is make a cup of coffee and
usually I have that first cup of coffee
on the front porch sit out there watch
the Sun come up
certainly every morning I go out for a
walk
I check in at 10:00
[Music]
hey good morning
I have 67 I take the weather every day
at 2:00 and check out at 4:15
[Music]
I think the solitary nature when there's
really no fire is going the only thing I
might do is check in on the radio twice
a day that might be the only time I
really talk unless I'm talking to myself
I think what's so tricky sometimes
talking about the lookout experience is
you're not talking to anybody about it
so you more intuitive you more
experience it I think that's why I was
used a term resonance because you just
can feel it and sense it maybe that's
fanciful but it certainly is the way I
feel about it you know you just find
yourself sitting on the porch watching
the world go by for hours on end it's
it's beautiful when you look at you know
lifestyle of a fire lookout it can be a
hard choice at times to you know I'm
missing a wedding tonight over the
course of summer you might miss a lot of
stuff in your life but certainly every
summer I keep coming back because living
on top of the mountain for days on end
it's just such a beautiful chance at
making a life of it
[Music]
I had no idea what apartments for us and
then I saw it I was like mama why didn't
you get me one and now I'm doing bar
mitzvahs booked out three years in
advance my name is Kareem Wells and
everybody called me the King on a missus
I once shared part of my heart and a
part of my life when I was 16 I had my
first kid I was kicked out of high
school so I did what most people my age
did I turned to the streets I started
selling drugs I chose that because I
felt like I had no other option I grew
up on the west side of Chicago in a
neighborhood where it was a lot of
violence drug dealer a lot of illegal
activity this is West Garfield Park and
this is where my house used to be a toy
down it is just a lot I had dreams you
know doing music and I loved performance
the OGIS from the neighborhood they
encouraged me to get out they pushed me
to follow my dream this guy we knew he
was gonna make it and he managed to
floor that one off man and I'm not proud
of the man the thing that the
neighborhood gave me was toughness and
how to hustle never give up so when I'm
out here doing these bar mitzvahs I'm
gonna be strong with it you know I'm
gonna give 200% I'm gonna be the best at
it
where's everybody all right yeah let's
just meet real quick and just talk about
what we're gonna do the way that I got
involved in the midst of business well I
got a call one day from a half-brother
who told me that there was this party
going on and he said we needed answer so
I go over there and I see what's going
on I actually thought it was a 50th
birthday party but it turns out that it
was a party for a 13 year old boy
what's up the people saw the way we was
doin parties the way we was bringing the
energy the way we carried I sales with
the kids
we carried ourselves with the family it
was like we gotta get there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
listen when you walk into a party that
I'm emceeing you're gonna feel the
energy the moment you walk in the room
and it's gonna be wild and crazy and
everybody's gonna be having the time of
their life we can celebrate just about
to get a crazy night is the memory that
that kid will never forget you have some
haters that think it's kind of funny
that a black kid from the west side of
Chicago is doing bar mitzvahs I say to
them I'm the best in my shoes and I get
to experience life at a level that I
never expected I would be I never
thought in a million years that I would
be the owner entertainment company for
Bar Mitzvahs
I am living proof that you can come from
absolutely some very horrendous
circumstances and you can make some
money yourself if you never give up the
success that this has brought me it put
me in a peaceful place I'm getting paid
to make people happy today is insane and
I just feel great
you